Happy Birthday, to you!
and many more!
and many more
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new black panther 2 movie video
marvel also just dropped that brand new intro
for the marvel movies honoring chadwick boseman
so i'll explain what's going on with that and
what they've said about black panther 2 so far
if you're new to the channel we're doing the
spider-man miles morales playstation 5 game
giveaway or for ps4 all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your theories about
black panther 2 on the video but just starting
at the beginning if you don't know what's going
on marvel just recently released their new marvel
movies intro with chadwick boseman obviously they
did the same thing for stan lee during the captain
marvel movie intro right after he passed away at
the time he passed away he'd already filmed his
cameo scene for avengers end game so that movie
was technically his final marvel movie cameo scene
but captain marvel was just the next marvel movie
in theaters after he passed away so marvel didn't
want to wait a couple more months to do that intro
for the avengers end game intro the reason why
marvel waited till this past week to release
this new chadwick boseman marvel movies intro is
because they were waiting till the anniversary
of his birthday he would have turned 44 years old
this past week so they released this on his actual
birthday and if you go watch the black panther
movie now on disney plus they've already updated
the movie in this new intro plays at the beginning
of that it's permanent now and eventually when
they release the black panther 2 movie in may 2022
which is when it's currently scheduled to come out
this is the same marvel intro with chadwick
boseman that's going to play during that movie too
the other videos of them celebrating his actual
birthday on the set of avengers infinity war you
can tell that it's infinity war because you see
scarlett johansson's black widow stunt double in
the background with that short blonde hairdo
in the infinity war costumes but number four
you may have recently seen in all the trades
deadline variety hollywood reporter the rap
they've all been reporting a bunch of new details
marvel had released about the upcoming marvel
phase 4 and marvel phase 5 movies in disney plus
series there's obviously a lot more going on with
that this week too that's brand new but a couple
weeks ago as part of that they revealed a bunch
of new details about what's happening with black
panther 2 and how marvel is planning on handling
chadwick boseman's death around the story of
the movie because obviously it prevents some
challenges for them all the top marvel brass
kevin feige even ryan coogler the director of
the black panther movies in black panther 2 and a
close personal friend of chadwick boseman revealed
after he'd passed away that they had no idea
what was going on with his diagnosis at the time
he'd chosen to keep that private from all of
his movie collaborators he'd worked with since
he learned he had cancer back in 2016. before they
started filming the first black panther movie this
is around captain america civil war era so you
have to keep that in mind when you go back and you
watch all of his marvel movies or his other movies
during that stretch of time because he was very
prolific he did a lot of other really great movies
that were not marvel movies he spent all of his
time between those movies undergoing extreme chemo
and cancer treatments which are incredibly painful
on their own to say nothing of what the cancer
does to your body but when you actually go back
and you watch those movies he took it like such a
champ you wouldn't have thought that anything was
wrong with him at the time and apparently neither
did kevin feige ryan coogler or any of the marvel
people so they were heading into 2021 planning
on doing black panther 2 with this completely
different story his family even said right up
until the week before he passed away earlier
this summer that he was absolutely confident
he'd be able to gain back all the weight that
he'd lost in time to start filming black panther 2
next year in 2021 and originally before the virus
delayed everything separately before he passed
away they had planned to start filming the movie
in spring 2021 that's changed just a little bit
now mostly because of virus delays and because
of what happened with chadwick boseman so number
three now all the hollywood trades are reporting
the movie's going to start filming in july next
year that was actually the first news we'd heard
since chadwick boseman passed away about the
movie marvel still hasn't really said much other
than that besides ryan coogler coming forward to
make a statement honoring his life and saying that
they would continue to honor his memory with their
future work which is why they're not going to do
any kind of deep fake situation the other marvel
producers also confirm we're not going to fake
chadwick boseman into the movie with some crazy
cg solution but they are still going to make black
panther too so obviously the story will have to be
very different from what they'd originally planned
but it will still focus heavily on t'challa he'll
still be a really core part of the film they're
not going to write him out of the movie in some
weird way so even though he's going to be one of
the most important characters in the movie it's
just not going to be in the way you would have
expected previously now it's being reported by all
the trades that shuri's role is being elevated big
time and she'll be much more of a main character
than she would have before she was already
important to the story before as you would expect
it's just that now they're kind of implying that
they're going to follow some of the black panther
comic book story during the mid to late 2000s they
did the doom war comics arc where dr doom invades
wakanda to steal all their vibranium as you do if
you're a marvel villain i know everyone would love
to see dr doom be the villain of black panther 2.
they haven't confirmed any of that still wide open
in theory crafting i have a feeling we won't see
doctor doom in the mcu until they get closer
to doing an actual fantastic four mcu movie
but during that storyline shuri becomes the new
black panther because t'challa trains her just in
case anything were ever to happen to him and he
winds up getting stuck in limbo in a lot of his
statements when ryan coogler was honoring chadwick
boseman's memory after he passed away one of the
things he said was that he was with the ancestors
now so i think it's pretty easy to assume that
they'll have a scene like that during the movie
like they did during the first black panther
film where he goes into the realm of the ancestors
and speaks to his father t'chaka only this time
it will be shuri speaking to t'challa and even if
they don't want to try and use a cg version of his
character they can still use old footage of him
and work it in and make it seem like new footage
or they can just have him appear to her as an
actual panther that doesn't speak with words
just communicates with her silently that's really
just a small part of the film though t'challa will
still be a much more important character and
presence during the film just not in the way
you would expect it number two the only villain
right now that's been officially reported is
tenoch huerta from narcos mexico they didn't say
which marvel villain character he be playing is
still a bit of a mystery only that he'd be one of
the villains implying that there will be multiple
villains during the film and a lot of people did
feel like even though they want namor to be the
main villain of the film he's not an exact dead
ringer for namor the reason why most people want
to name war as the main villain is because he's
such an iconic black panther villain in the comics
and they had that avengers end game atlantis scene
with the underwater earthquake the funny thing
about that scene is that the writers for avengers
endgame said that they did that with the intention
of laying seeds that marvel could always pick up
on later if they wanted but they're not the ones
that are writing black panther to ryan coogler is
so it's up to him to pick who the main villains
are going to be the other big villain of the first
black panther movie that ryan coogler originally
wanted to do was Kraven the hunter but they opted
to go for a killmonger instead i think they made
the right call in that instance and Kraven's
been rumored in the new spider-man movies but
one of the other big core black panther comic book
villains people have been talking about recently
is the white wolf the thing about that character
though is they'd have to change his backstory a
little because originally he was t'challa's secret
brother and they kind of already did that secret
family member twist with killmonger's backstory
so it would be kind of redundant for another
quote-unquote secret heir to the throne to come
forward if there's going to be any kind of battle
for the throne internally in wakanda it would be
between shuri and umbaku because originally during
the first black panther movie when they thought
that t'challa had died they were taking that last
remaining heart-shaped herb plant baku for him to
use and gain the powers of black panther so that
he'd be strong enough to get rid of killmonger and
then after that would arguably take the throne of
wakanda because he'd already tried to lay claim
but had been beaten by t'challa so he was already
kind of their number two pick for the king of
wakanda even though the royal line of succession
passes to shuri but that's only if she can win
against any potential challengers to the throne
per their customs in number one probably most
importantly just in terms of how they'd address
black panther's powers in the mantle now that
killmonger has destroyed all the heart-shaped
herb that we know of if you've read any of the
new marvel mcu books there's a new one called
the wakanda files that gets into this it has a
bunch of extra canonical information for all the
avengers characters and movies like the characters
tech their powers all the minor things that the
movies brush over like what was going on in iron
man's head when he was designing spider-man's
iron spider armor just really cool stuff during
that book they also revealed that shuri had been
working on a way to replicate the effects of the
heart-shaped herb using technology and science
right up until avengers infinity war in avengers
end game so really cool iron man mcu easter egg
shuri is kind of an iron man type of character
in that all of her abilities already come from
her technology like iron man doesn't have special
powers he makes technology that gives him the same
powers as one of the other major avengers like
thor she was even able to reprogram vision's mind
based on all the infinity stone technology before
he died i mean thanos ripped his head open so it's
not like he's going to survive that they'll get
into that during the Wandavision series don't
worry but we'll learn a bunch more details about
the black panther 2 movie and how marvel is going
to handle all this stuff by next summer when
they start filming and which other characters
are going to be introducing i know you're all
hoping for more x-men characters and mutants
because they just announced the new deadpool 3
movie inside the mcu but post all your theories
in the comments below and leave all your requests
for marvel videos congratulations mackenzie spence
you're the giveaway winner for my last spider-man
miles morales ps5 giveaway please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can get your
contact details everyone click here for my new
mandalorian season 2 episode 5 ahsoka tano video
and click here for that new mandalorian season 2
new jedi characters teaser thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe wakanda forever!